>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATIC
STRONGHOLD OF SAN FRANCISCO HAS
BECOME, WELL, ESPECIALLY IN
DOWNTOWN, A FESTERING PILE OF
GARBAGE FECES AND DRUG NEEDLES.
ACCORDING TO A SURVEY THE
INVESTIGATION OF 153 CITY BLOCKS
INCLUDING POPULAR TOUR SPOTS
FOUND TRASHED ON EVERY BLOCK 300
PILES OF FECES ON 96 BLOCKS,
LOVELY.
100 DISCARDED HYPODERMIC NEEDLES
ON 41 BLOCKS.
THAT'S ALL.
THIS IS A SANCTUARY CITY, IS IT?
IS A LOCAL DELI OWNER.
HE SPAT UP.
>> IT'S FILTHY.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
YESTERDAY WE TAPED SOMEBODY JUST
ON THE SIDE OF MY BUILDING
PEEING ON MY RESTAURANT IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT.
I ACTUALLY HAVE PICTURES OF
PEOPLE SHOOTING UP IN THE
STREET.
POINT.
IT'S COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL.
>> Laura: I HAD A CALL OR MY
RADIO SHOWS TODAY SO SHE WENT TO
SAN FRANCISCO RECENTLY WITH HER
KIDS AND SHE ALSO SAW SOMEONE
SHOOTING UP ON THE SIDE OF THE
STREET, TYING UP THE ARM,
PUTTING THE NEEDLE, SHE HAD TO
SHIELD HER DAUGHTER'S EYES.
NOT EXACTLY A PARADISE FOR
BUSINESSES OR WORKERS.
JOINING US NOW, SAN FRANCISCO
REPUBLICAN PARTY VICE CHAIR KEN
LU IS ALSO A POLICE -- AND
ETHAN, A POLITICAL COMMENTATOR
IN THE BAY AREA RADIO HOST.
ETHAN, I LOVE SAN FRANCISCO.
I LOVE IT.
I HAVE FRIENDS THERE.
I'VE BEEN GOING FOR A LONG TIME.
IT HAS A MAJOR PROBLEM AND I
DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, OR SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN, IT'S NOT GETTING
BETTER, IT SEEMS TO BE GETTING
WORSE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IT'S TRUE.
IT IS PROBLEMATIC.
I WILL SAY THAT UNDER MAYOR ED
LEE, WHO RECENTLY PASSED AWAY,
WE PRODUCED A NUMBER OF VETERANS
WHO ARE HOMELESS IN THE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
WE ARE TAKING AN APPROACH.
BUT REMEMBER, WE ARE BEING
HANDCUFFED BY A NUMBER OF LAWS
THAT PROHIBIT THE ABILITY OF
TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND MAKING
THEM GET THE PSYCHIATRIC CARE
THAT THEY NEED.
GETTING THEM THE ADDICTIVE CARE.
WE ALLOW PEOPLE UNDER THE GUISE
OF CIVIL LIBERTIES TO BE FREE
AND NOT PUT THEM IN PLACES TO
GET THE HELP THAT THEY NEED TO
PROTECT AND HELP THEMSELVES, LET
ALONE OTHERS AND ALLOW THEM TO
BECOME CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY AGAIN.
THIS IS A REALLY BIG ISSUE.
IT NOBODY TO STEP IN FECES.
I HAVE CHILDREN, I DON'T LIKE
FINDING USED NEEDLES.
BUT THERE ARE APPROACHES THAT
THE CITY IS TRYING BUT WE
ACTUALLY NEED SOME FEDERAL HELP
IN THIS CASE, IN MY OPINION,
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE HOMELESS
ARE NOT FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
THEY COME BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO FREEZE TO DEATH WHEN WE
ARE HAVING A COLD SNAP, UNLIKE
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: ARE YOU BLAMING FROM
FOR THIS?
YOU BLAMING DONALD TRUMP FOR THE
FACT THAT --
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THIS IS A SUCCESSIVE SERIES OF
ISSUES AND COURT RULINGS FOR
THAT MATTER.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT.
WE HAD FOUR FEDERAL COURTS RULED
THAT WE CAN'T DO CERTAIN THINGS.
>> Laura: DON'T GET ME STARTED
ON THE JUDGES.
I'M GOING TO DO A WHOLE BIG
SEGMENT ON THE JUDGES TOMORROW.
ED  LET'S GO TO YOU ON THIS.
THIS IS SO SAD ON SO MANY LEVELS
THIS IS SO SAD ON SO MANY LEVEL
LEVELS.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
PROGRESSIVE PARADISE OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S A SUPER DEMOCRAT MAJORITY,
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
YEARS -- GOING BACK TO GAVIN
NEWSOM WHEN HE TRIED TO GET RID
OF THE CASH -- REMEMBER THE CASH
FOR THE HOMELESS?
THEY FOUGHT HIM BACK THEN.
HE WAS MY FIRST GUEST BY THE WAY
ON MY RADIO SHOW THAT I EVER HAD
17 YEARS AGO, IT WAS GAVIN
NEWSOM.
BUT TO ME IT'S GOTTEN WORSE AND
WORSE EVEN WITH SOME MODEST
IMPROVEMENTS AROUND THE EDGES.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> Laura: I THINK WE ARE
HAVING -- ARE WE HAVING AUDIO
PROBLEMS?
>> I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT.
>> Laura: ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S DIRECTED TO YOU.
>> SAN FRANCISCO HASN'T HAD A
REPUBLICAN ELECTED OFFICE FOR
MULTIPLE DECADES NOW.
SO NONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN TERMS OF THE
HOMELESS YEAR CAN BE ATTRIBUTED
TO THE REPUBLICANS AT ALL IN
SAN FRANCISCO, SIMPLY BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A SINGLE REPUBLICAN
ELECTED TO OFFICE REPRESENTING
SAN FRANCISCO.
THE HOMELESS EPIDEMIC THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT HERE IS JUST GETTING
WORSE.
IN FACT, EVERY YEAR -- I WAS
BORN HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I
CAN SEE PROGRESSIVELY EVERY YEAR
THE PROBLEM HAS BEEN GETTING
WORSE AND WORSE EVERY YEAR WITH
NO SOLUTIONS.
I'VE MET WITH MULTIPLE BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR MEMBERS HERE IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND THEY JUST KEEP
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY.
WHEN THEY ASK FOR MORE MONEY IT
IS BASICALLY REWARDING A PROGRAM
THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
BENCHMARKS.
THERE IS NO SOLUTION IN THEIR
SOLUTION IS TO JUST THROW MORE
MONEY AT THE PROBLEM.
>> Laura: WHAT THEY'RE ALSO
DOING IS DECLARING THEMSELVES
YEAR AFTER YEAR, WE ARE A
SANCTUARY CITY, SANCTUARY STATE.
SEE THE PROBLEM IN
ORANGE COUNTY, WE SEE THE
PROBLEM IN L.A.
WE ARE BRINGING MORE PEOPLE INTO
THE SITUATION.
MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE INDIGENT AND
THEMSELVES ARE WITHOUT JOBS AT A
WAY TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES.
I DON'T SEE HOW THE SANCTUARY
STATUS OF SAN FRANCISCO OR THE
STATE IS DOING ANYBODY ANY
FAVORS.
ETHAN AND KAREN, GREAT SEGMENT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.